ITS NOW TIME FOR THE
HASHTAG WARS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: THE D-O DOUBLE G
HOSTED THE BET HIP HOP AWARDS
TONIGHT AND ONCE AGAIN, I WAS
SNUBBED.
HOW MANY TIMES DO I HAVE TO NOT
RELEASE A HIP-HOP ALBUM?
SO IN HONOR OF HIP HOPPING MOST
PRESTIGIOUS NIGHT, TONIGHT'S
HASHTAG IS #HIPHOPBOOKS.
EXAMPLES MAY BE HARRY POTTER AND
THE 36 CHAMBERS.
SUGE KNIGHT MOON.
OR TUPAC A MOCKINGBIRD.
GOD DAMNIT. DON'T SUPPORT THAT.
I WILL PUT 60-SECONDS ON THE
OLD CLOCK. GO.
JUSTIN WILLMAN.
>> TO THE COUNT OF MONTY
KRISTOL.
>> Chris: YES. POINTS.
MAMRIE.
>> HORTON HEARS A WHO DAT.
>> Chris: YES POINTS.
MAMRIE
LUDA-CHRISTMAS CAROL.
>> Chris: POINTS. JUSTIN.
>> LIL WOMEN.
>> Chris: POINTS. JONAH.
>> A LOT OF PEOPLE WALKIN'
AROUND LIKE THEY GOT SOMETHING
TO SAY, BUT NOTHING EVER COMES
OUT WHEN THEY MOVE THEIR LIPS.
JUST A BUNCH OF GIBBERISH, LIKE
THEY FORGOT ABOUT 50 SHADES OF
DRE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> HOLY (BLEEP).
>> Chris: THAT WAS MASTERFUL.
JUSTIN.
>> THE GRAPE SODA OF WRATH.
>> Chris: POINTS. JUSTIN.
>> A TALE OF TWO CHAINS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JONAH.
>> ATLAS THUG.
>> Chris: POINTS. JUSTIN.
>> SNOOP LION, THE WITCH, AND
THE WARDROBE.
>> Chris: POINTS. JONAH.
>> THE BIBLE, WRITTEN BY KANYE
WEST.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JUSTIN.
>> WIZ KHALIFA OF A OZ
>> Chris: POINTS.
MAMRIE.
>> THE GIRL WITH THE TEAR DROP
TATTOO.
>> Chris: POINTS.